it's
Saturday and I'm sitting
alone in my apartment at my desk staring
at my
computer like
99% of every other
Saturday and I went to get a
pizza because I still don't know how to
eat right
and you know Dartmouth is graduated or
graduating
and this always happens when I drive in
on the weekend to get my unhealthy food
that I eat alone in my apartment and I
see all of them holding hands walking
down to the river to swim sitting out on
the green with friends or going back to
their dorm so they can probably do stuff
later because it's a Saturday and I get
my
pizza and I go back to my
apartment
because I don't have any
friends and honestly I don't think I've
ever had friends not like real friends I
mean obviously I had like friends in
high school and
college but it was the most superficial
level if I was in class I would have
people to talk to people liked me I
don't think I was a totally unlikable
person and I would do after school
activities and people would talk to me
and I had people that I was close
to but we never did anything at besides
that I never did anything after school
in high school if I did it
was it was rare like the times like prom
mom had to ask a friend son to ask me
and then he left early with another girl
which at the time I thought was
hilarious because I could tell a story
to my friends and maybe that would be
interesting on in I'll see him on
Instagram but I we we've never hung out
with any of my friends from high school
same thing with college
I mean started senior year but you know
like the second people started doing
stuff on the weekends I was always alone
in my dorm room watching all the other
kids walk to the
parties I've never had a
friend that I would just spend time with
and tell everything
to I really thought I got close with
Caitlyn and Molly and Katrina and
Aaron
and it's been two
years made a single friend and there was
a girl I met on Bumble
but I never went anywhere and she moved
and you know what it's my fault because
you know I complain about not having
anyone but this the minute anyone does
come to my life and I have a chance I do
nothing with it she invited me over to
your apartment we P I couldn't would
have talked to her but every time she
texted me I would wait like a day to
respond and when we made plans I would
feel awkward about it cuz all I wanted
to do was be back in my apartment um
this is going to sound up to say
but I really love this video You're an
introvert um I won't say introvert but I
think what I love about this video is
like she knows she has a problem and she
knows her own role in the problem yep
like I'm watching this like there
something I sympathize with because like
I moved a lot after the military I was
never in one place for long so like
building long-lasting friendship wasn't
the easiest thankfully the certain
Hobbies I was able to scr but I
understand and I think one thing I
learned over time is like these
relationships take time and effort and
much like
relationships with intimate partner
people often think that their
friendships are just supposed to happen
but the reality is they require effort
they require time they require presence
they require intentionality and a lot of
people take that stuff for granted and
so when they're not able to F these
kinds of relationships it's like doesn't
really happen you know sometimes people
don't have friends it's like well how
many times have you shown up to their
special events how many times have you
guys reached up to spend time offline
how many times have they messaged you
and you've really messaged in a timely
manner or you've reached out to them and
vice versa has to be mutual too
obviously can't be one-sided because
then you just feel neglected and you're
putting effort to somebody who doesn't
so I love the fact that she acknowledges
that she's had opportunities but she let
them slip through their hands and it's
caused a lot of her suffering not I go
oh it's your fault but it's like if you
understand the way you wish you
contribute there's ways in which you can
find remedies to that so the
self-awareness is I think what I'm
appreciating about this CU too many
people get on L you complain about these
issues or they vent about these issues
in a valid way but then they don't
really self assess and see the ways in
which they're destructive to their own
outcomes that they want whenever she
said that I was waiting for that cuz
that was the first question that popped
up in my head like so what did you do
though that's the first thing cuz you
have to entertain those things you know
what I mean so if you have friends and
you have people that you call friends I
mean um which is by the way friends is a
term that is used too vely true it's too
much some of you some of the people that
you call friends are not friends okay
you have to make the difference between
an acquaintance a
job person that you know someone that
you were colleague there's a difference
between friend colleague uh
acquaintances there's a lot of people
that I know that's like oh that's my
friend I can't believe it did did why
cuz it's my friend well if you think
about it you just know that from
work at the beginning of a relationship
you're going to water a plant you're
going to water a plant you're going to
water a plant a lot because it's in the
growing phases it needs to get that
strength so that whenever you forget to
water it once or twice cuz sometimes
people are going to be busy that's what
I mean by not watering your plant people
are going to be busy you're not going to
be able to go out with your friends or
life is going to be happening on their
side on your side things are going to be
overwhelming you're you're not going to
be able to reach out so that that plant
your relationship doesn't die out
because you already watered it and you
fortified it and has all the nutrient to
grow so that whenever you don't have
time to water it it's still going to be
there so when you come back to it you're
like hey you know what now I got more
time I water it it's still going to be
both to flourish and to grow you
understand your friendship are not going
to be always out a high it's going to be
sometime out a low sometimes you're not
going to have time my apartment that in
my I'm in my apartment I'm
alone so it's like
what the is wrong with me that I
complain about this and
then I make no effort to try to change
it I mean ever since I
started applying to gr SCH I gave up and
trying to make friends
here and it's noticeable My Le Lord
Elaine keeps commenting on how all of
her past tenants do things on the
weekends basically calling me like a
friendless loser which is true but like
to hear her just say that to me was
really
hard I don't know if your landlord was
trying to call you a friendless loser
could be I I the way I understood it was
like student tenants are generally very
messy and go out and make a lot of noise
and do a lot of stuff and it's
refreshing having a tenant who doesn't
cause problems who doesn't host parties
and who doesn't come back late now
you're allowing to internalize it I
don't know so I could be wrong but it
just that's how it sounded to me bro you
are 100% right we all appreciate do you
know as a as a landlord how it is to
have people you notice when people are
messy or when they give you back the
apartment and you going that and
you're
like how is there on the ceiling
but maybe this landlord's different he
like yo you ain't got no friends loser
loser that's a crazy that's a crazy
landlord I know me if I was in llord I
would want somebody who keeps it
themselves and doesn't cause problems
and it's very me anyone tells me I'm
young
and I have
time but it's still
hard so gross I'm sorry I didn't I know
I was emotional I didn't think good
crying like
this I just don't know what's wrong with
me that I
can't make it work that I'm just lazy
when it comes to making
friends I just want it to be easy you
know when you just find that person that
you're with all the time so see that's
operative where you want it to be easy
it's like for a lot of people who
maintain friendships very seamlessly
it's because they've been doing it for
so long so it's easy to them it's kind
of like going to the gym some people
find it very difficult to go and others
it's super easy but they've also made it
part of their routine so they've adapted
to their schedule and their time
environment and made the commitment but
it is an effort even for the people who
was easy to go to the gym they're just
used to doing it for a lot of people
they think friendships is just is
supposed to happen it's that's not the
way it works at least like even family
relationships they require effort if you
don't reply to your family if you don't
show up if you don't make an effort to
respond like a lot of families will stop
being that close same thing with
relationships like none of these things
are different so me hearing her language
I understand what she's wanting but what
she's wanting is not gain the way she
wants it she knows a problem she's just
not ready to take the steps and she
wants it to be easy cuz she wants the
benefit of a friendship with the labor
that's involved and the actual work
she's not ready to do it's just like
it's just it's like comedy for some
people I know some people that are
generally funny they funny in real life
like you meet them they're always funny
always have the thing to make you laugh
it's funny for them and they do comedy
and they're doing good and even for them
that it's still funny and easy to be
it's easy to be funny for them they
still have to work they still have to
show up they have to show book up and
they have to travel and have you seen
someone that is generally funny but
doesn't want to do the work they don't
go anywhere it's still it's still it it
lasts but not for a long time and after
that it fades it fades CU and all the
people the people that are not so funny
or less funny that do the work that do
that show up that put can actually
surpass them and I've seen that numerous
and numerous and numerous time whether
it's easy for you or it's not you still
got to put the work in and you got to
show up and you got to do this you got
to do these things unpleasant but yeah
all the darkness
students
and they're really cute
outfits walking around
downtown holding hands walking down to
the river to swim walking to their
apartment I'm sorry jeez what you got
sitting out on the green with
friends you're actually so
stupid you're actually so goddamn dumb
bro that shit's
crazy why you got n n that's crazy that
was
mad
yo else you watching
bro you know damn well I ain't got to
say nothing you know what the you
did don't don't act like
yeah dumb smile I do yeah okay what all
right you know what you're only mad
because that pop top in your head
but I was brave enough to say it no it
didn't pop up my head make my way down
it didn't pop up my head but once you
said it I could hear it okay you can
hear it I'm not
crazy okay you could hear it so I'm not
crazy all right let's keep watching cuz
Okay no no no hold on the thing that
happened is that it's my add all right
when is too long my brain wanders
off so I don't know what this thing how
long are we at let's just we got to
watch this I know your mind wanders so
do your thing okay I'll do my
thing
and it's been hard especially with Mom
and Dad because before I would just talk
to them because I had no one
else but now with all the divorce stuff
there's stuff I can't talk to them about
and I have know and Travis and Kyle are
too emotional and I can't talk to
anyone I just look at myself and I don't
know the W sting all these
days I just I need to I just want to I
just feel so lonely
I'm just so lonely all the
time and but I'm also terrified of it
and I also want to be alone like do I
maybe I'm just meant to be alone no no I
think your videos obviously cry for help
I don't think you're meant to be alone
but you got to put the effort I think
listen this is something that's becoming
more and more common for us nowadays MH
as we live online more we spend more
times on our phones less times outside
less time engaging in real life
activities it's harder for people to
build those kinds of connections you
know where you used to do certain stuff
you go to the park everyone go to the
same plots now we're so online that
we're you know having friends in
Budapest why we live in Hungary or we
live in Siberia or whatever it might be
like just people have friends all over
and it's like made inperson friendships
a lot more difficult one two it's also
just made people have a harder time
connecting with people in a very
powerful way because I think friendships
generally get deeper and stronger as
you're able to share things with people
go through things with them sometimes
you fall out you fall back in but you
need to have things that tie you
together and nowadays we just have
everything all the tools that are
disposable disposal to disconnect rather
than make it super easy to connect does
that make sense like it's just so easy
you just delete people from your friend
group you'll never see them again if you
don't want to you're not going out as
often because like who wants to go out
you just stay at home watch Netflix blah
blah blah so I I just think the way we
have Society set up is very easy to cut
people out which sounds odd because we
live in a time of ultimate connectivity
but the kind of connectivity we're
generally discussing are very shallow
bonds so I sympathize with her because I
think being lonely is super uh sad I
think for most people who live that life
it negatively impacts him as shows a
steady so do I think she's meant to be
alone probably not I don't think most
people are um and I hope for her that
stuff gets fixed cuz I don't wish that
on anybody I know what life is like for
me when I don't have my friends around
or when I don't get like
honestly if you have good friends good
quity friends spending time with them is
like sometimes the highlight of your
week y'all Sit down you're not thinking
about work you're not thinking about all
the other stress you just y chopping it
up sharing references about different
things bringing up memories you haven't
thought of getting C off of people you
care about it's like it's own little web
drama that's you're involved in and it's
so outside of your day-to-day it's so
refreshing to just be able to kick it
and have like-minded people kind of
soundboard things off of you and talk
about things so I don't know for me I
think I think people should seek that
out I think it's very healthy for people
I know it's been very healthy for me so
I hope she finds that and uh I don't
know I just want to commend her for
being both vulnerable being
introspective being critical of herself
and then also of like you know just
being very raw about everything so
that's what I want to say well you said
something about the communication era uh
we are in a communication era the thing
with that is that the easier something
becomes the more we take it for granted
okay right for a certain time first we
just use it we use it we use it and
after that like G yeah that thing is
there if I want to remember emails the
first time that we wanted emails we're
like oh my God this is the greatest
thing and then we got an email and then
we're super sighted about it until we
get like a bunch
of ads all day and everything and stuff
we just take it for granted like we have
so many things and apps to communicate
but we take it for granted because we
can do it so easily true it's easy to do
like it is about on your phone there's
about 12 10 to 10 to 15 ways to
communicate with someone including your
phone that is you know well use it to
phone people so there's that but we also
take it for granted it's easy to do so
you postpone it for later and and it it
kind of uh puts the effort it's easy to
do
but it's easy to do but it's not easy to
do it's easy to do but because it's easy
to do we don't think about it we put it
over there I actually think because it's
easy to do it's hard to do yes because
it's not rewarding no and so you have to
muster up the energy yeah and you're
just like why am I do this it's not
rewarding I scroll Tik Tok when I can do
all this other bunch of that's
not really but it affects you mentally
yeah it is rewarding I literally have to
teach myself it is it is rewarding going
on Tik Tok or whatever because it gives
you endres and stuff like that and blah
blah whatever what not but not in a
meaningful way yes but the drugs and the
endrine that it releases is actually
more addictive than whatever it is to
communicate with people so that's the
problem that we have and that's the loop
that we have and then you said something
as well that is you know even though
we're in the area of communication back
then we needed to to live in community
whether it was for protection whether it
was just to to to you you have to go I
can't be a farmer and just grow my stuff
I need to buy other stuff so I need to
go to the market and interact with
people now I can order in I can order
all that stuff
out before you kind of had a you had to
when you were irit you made a corporate
decision to live without our people you
refuted people you you you you made a
decision to go out there and live alone
that's that was a dis to the rest of the
people them you know what I mean so now
it's not really that much hard so you
have to make an extra effort because
that being alone is right there okay you
don't need those people that much so you
do have to make an effort right there
and that's a reason why it is harder so
even even though we are in the
communication era we have those apps but
it is kind of harder because we take
that for granted Absolutely I'll
say this this is my suggestions to folks
watching if you're struggling with a lot
of this I've only really have two
suggestions that I can really think of
go ahead one is you you you have to make
the effort even if you don't want to so
that you can learn to make that a habit
I find it easy to message my mom today
cuz I've been making an effort for the
last 3 to four years but sometimes back
in the day I used to not mess with my
mom for months and it would be normal to
me not because I think it's a good thing
it was just the way I develop my habits
and I had to do that with the people in
my life as well I had to learn to be
like yo let me just check in on these
people cuz I love them and I I just you
know I'm going to do it right now I'm
not going to postpone it and I think in
doing that I started developing better
habits and I like I message regularly my
mom appreciates it and some of the
people my life appreciate it too so I
think it's like something you have to
push yourself to do to build that the
same way you have to push yourself to
start going to the gym and make it a
habit if you want it to really be
ingrain you have to do that with other
things in your life if you don't the
things that you think are supposed to
just happen will never happen you're not
just magically going get into shape if
you don't show up to work out on a
regular basis it's just not going to
happen so that' be suggestion number one
push yourself to do it it could be small
little things can start it once a week
once every two weeks but if that's
substantially better than what the
you're doing now do it okay um because
you really have no excuse you're
spending all your day on other social
media apps looking at looking
at titties some random dances some dumb
videos like how like if you love
these people it requires a bit of
devotion it requires a bit of Labor and
if you're not willing to do the modum of
Labor that it
costs can you really claim that you
really love these people is something to
question a little bit in terms of your
actions maybe internally mentally you
really feel that way but sometimes your
actions don't align with what it is that
you're saying and you're doing so just
think about that cuz I know you guys if
you were in a relationship with somebody
didn't matter who it was and you told
that woman or that man I'm in love with
you okay and they say the same but they
never responded to your text messages or
took months I think you would doubt that
I think you would I'm not saying you
need the same level of devotion in
relationship that you need to your
friendships but there should be some
measure of like semblance it shouldn't
be like night and day it shouldn't be I
message my partner but I never reply to
my friends or I talk with my friends
once a year only it's like now some
friendships are built like that some
people they they have their families and
so but I'm saying if you're suffering
from that sense of loneliness and not
having those people in your life and you
want that and you're not doing those
steps for me is a little bit bizarre
that's one and two that that was two so
I guess that's three now what was no
it's all one right make effort no no no
you said and secondly you I think I just
went back to the first point oh okay
cool uh but two what I was going to say
is if you're finding hard to even find
people to connect with you have to find
the things that make you connect to
people some people it's their Shar
highest experience of being in high
school together and going to college
together being from the same
neighborhood if you don't have those
experiences then you have to find the
hobbies and the things that intersect
between you and other if it's not
proximity it's got to be
interests why because these things help
Bond you guys going through things going
through classes going through activities
tournaments whatever the it is like
how many people do I know who go play
pickup basketball on a regular basis or
have like intramural tournaments and
stuff like that and the people on their
team they go grab beers with afterwards
and start to build friendships from
there maybe not everyone on the team but
a few of them like those activities Bond
you you need things to gel you to people
and if you don't have it with
history in proximity in terms of like
where y'all live or what kind of work
y'all did then you have to do things and
that's ways you have to put yourself out
there it's pretty much much it you have
to make the effort sometimes you know
you have to grab your and you know
making your way downtown and make
friends there you go and so we're not
going to play the rest of the video but
if you guys want to find it it's in the
description and now I
W